séance de travail particulières certains
élèves arrivent plus ou moins à l'heure
d'autres sont déjà plongés dans leur
cour trois histoires sociologie plus
d'une soixantaine de formations en bts
ou en licence peuvent être suivis ici à
autun un enseignement à son rythme
loin des contraintes des cours
universitaires traditionnelle dans un
amphi on peut pas forcément demandé aux
professeurs de revenir en arrière pour
expliquer alors là avec notre cour on
peut justement revoir le court comme on
l'entend revenir en arrière si on a
loupé avec le campus connecter plus
besoin de se déplacer physiquement dans
les établissements où l'on est inscrit
les étudiants intègrent un petit groupes
d'horizons divers un coach s'assure du
suivi de chacun
l'objectif c'est vraiment
d'individualiser les parcours là on fait
vraiment du sur-mesure c'est vraiment à
la carte
donc l'objectif lors des entretiens
individuels c'est vraiment de cerner les
difficultés et de répondre au mieux aux
attentes et aux besoins de chacun autre
avantage non négligeable pouvoir suivre
des cours hors des grandes métropoles
j'ai commencé pendant environ un mois
sur dijon je me suis rendu compte que
vraiment c'était très coûteux la vie
d'étudiante là-bas de payer les études
l'appartement les transports donc bien
sûr ça fait aussi un gain d'argent de
d'étudier à proximité de son domicile et
un intérêt pour la ville clairement
c'est de pouvoir garder des jeunes de
pouvoir les former l'idée c'est vraiment
de développer et de faire grandir ce
campus et de l'insérer dans un
environnement probablement en
centre-ville qui permette que nous
retrouvions une vie étudiante à autun
hautain et nevers font partie des 13
premières villes expérimentant ce
nouveau concept une centaine de campus
connectés seront déployés dans
l'hexagone d'ici l'horizon 2022